let's go next to our caller from the
five one five area code who's calling
today from five one five does that mean
yes is okay I'm Aaron I live in Iowa I
have like a couple questions all right
let's start with the best one
um I'm a Bernie supporter like through
and through and I love pretty much 90%
of his policies but like nationalised
$15 an hour wage I feel like would only
hurt many small communities I've talked
about this before and I talked about it
recently yeah I mean so so here's the
thing with the $15 minimum wage it's not
going to happen tomorrow so I'm okay
with talking about a national $15
minimum wage because by the time it's
implemented fully there will have been
more price inflation and we'll be
talking about you know years down the
line that's that I don't have a problem
with that it is true though that in
places where the minimum wage is seven
something an hour doubling it will have
an impact like every policy I've been
saying this all week I feel like in
different interviews I've done on the
Left we shouldn't be afraid to say that
policies have intended consequences and
sometimes unintended or less desirable
consequences in many places $15 is
probably too low because of the cost of
living there are other places where
doubling the minimum wage would have an
effect on employment and and you're
completely right and so I've been
talking about the minimum wage needing
to be looked at more as a regionalised
issue now the minimum wage still needs
to go up nationally it just might not
need to be 15 in every market but it is
it absolutely has to go up nationally um
my fear is that it will just see what
Amazon did where they can afford it but
the competitors can't and they're like
hey we'll pay $15 an hour we'll just cut
your benefit right yeah I mean listen I
think it's more raising the minimum wage
I think people should earn a living
based on where it is that they live in
there's drastically different costs of
living so I'm all about strengthening
labor in the United States and I want
people to be paid more in a lot of these
jobs where they're getting you know
eight nine bucks an hour but I also
think that we want to in the same way as
with Medicare for all I believe Medicare
for all would be night and day and
improvement over the system we have that
doesn't mean there aren't like three or
four questions about Medicare for all
which we should be comfortable raising
and saying here are the answers and
here's the question marks and it's still
a better system and though I wish the
left were you know we're fighting
against people who don't care about the
facts and that's why we end up having to
also take these black-white views on
things but when we're talking amongst
friends we should be able to have these
conversations
absolutely yeah like you said like I
believe like reformatting like our
Housing and Medicare for all and
allowing people to get back like their
voting rights and allowing them to like
actually move on past like prison
sentences like will help our economy
drastically it will help people actually
be able to afford to live and like I
don't know I feel like a ten dollar
minimum wage would be better
yeah I mean I don't want to throw out
any number but I am i I can see 15 would
be too high in some places on balance
accounting for the local economy and in
a lot of places it needs to be higher
than 15 is the reality because of the
cost of living that's outrageous yeah
where I live I make about five six
dollars over minimum wage and I still
cannot afford rent right late it's
insane yeah wait I don't understand how
people are out here barely making like
11 dollars and still like able to live
like Jesus well a lot of times they
can't or they have to live really far
away which increases absenteeism and you
know it's a whole cycle of problems that
we've talked about with many
externalities all right I appreciate the
call thank you for calling in today yep
all right thank you I apologize to
everybody I did not get to but alas we
are out of time we will take calls again
including during live streams upcoming
and next week as well